soll ein team an die spitze
die cdu diskutiert die führungsfrage und
der csu-chef will mitreden brisante
mission im südlichen mittelmeer die eu
schickt wieder marine schiffe vor der
küste von libyen
sie sollen verhindern dass waffen in das
bürgerkriegsland gebracht werden
konsequenzen für den todesraser nach
einem illegalen autorennen in moers
urteilt das gericht es war mord der
täter muss lebenslang in haft
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen in dieser
neuen woche hier ist ihr
nachrichtenüberblick heute um 7 sport
natürlich auch dabei nachher mit norbert
lehmann junior familie die offene
führungsfrage bei der cdu treibt beide
unionsparteien um die suche nach einer
neuen spitze und die frage wie lang
diese suche doch dauern soll und was das
für eine kanzlerkandidatur heißt ist
auch heute topthema und da kommt jetzt
erstens eine teamlösung ins spiel
und zweitens der csu-chef der ein
gewichtiges wort mitreden will danielsen
sie werde den prozess nun von vorne
führen hatte eine gate kramp-karrenbauer
vor einer woche gesagt doch vorne ist
nun vor allem er weil sein votum für die
kanzlerkandidatur mit entscheidend ist
formulierte csu-chef bedingungen und
empfehlungen erster vorfestlegungen das
mit dem parteivorsitz automatisch eine
kanzlerkandidatur verbunden sei das geht
natürlich nicht und zweitens ich glaube
die wähler und wähler wären es wird es
nicht gut finden wenn jetzt was irgend
welchen taktischen erwägungen die
regierungszeit der bundeskanzlerin
irgendwie bewusst verkürzen wolle
ich denke sie ist international mit
abstand die angesehenste politikerin in
deutschland das hieße anderthalb jahre
lang ein tandem merkel plus neuer
vorsitzender in welcher konstellation
dies funktionieren könnte gegebenenfalls
auch in welcher teamlösung darüber
spricht sie diese woche mit allen drei
kandidaten erst mit friedrich merz dann
mit jens spahn dann mit armin laschet
der heute in seiner heimat aachen einen
ic taufte wir warten erst einmal die
gespräche ab und teams sind immer gut
sowohl bei der bahn als auch ein punkt
war als auch in der politik dafür
brauche es aber auch teamgeist mahnen
parteimitglieder so müssten sich diesmal
auch alle unterlegenen hinter dem
versammeln das wird was ganz wichtig ist
dass wir uns kein zweites mal so einen
zirkus leisten können innerhalb der
partei
das fing schon an kurz nachdem annegret
kramp karrenbauer gewählt wurde dass
gegen sie agiert wurde und das ist kein
zustand
problematisch aus ihrer sicht war zudem
vor allem das nebeneinander von
parteivorsitz und kanzlerschaft wie die
cdu diese herausforderungen nun lösen
will bleibt unklar
die cdu führungskrise begann ja so
richtig durch den eklat bei der
thüringer ministerpräsidenten wahl vor
zwei wochen dort in erfurt suchen
vertreter von linken spd und grünen
heute nach einem ausweg und sprechen
dazu jetzt im moment mit abgeordneten
der cdu ex-regierungschef bodo ramelow
von der linkspartei will sich nur dann
noch mal zur wahl stellen wenn es für
ihn eine mehrheit ohne stimmen der afd
gibt dafür fehlen rot rot grün im
parlament aber vier stimmen
die müssten von der cdu oder von der fdp
kommen gucken wir live nach erfurt in
den landtag melanie haack guten abend
ist denn das für ramelow und die linke
zu schaffen
ja das ist die große frage die sich hier
alle stellen seit einer halben stunde
sitzen sie hier
hinter dieser tür zusammen wir warten
alle sind vier vertreter der cdu und
vertreter von den linken der spd und den
grünen
bodo ramelow zeigte klares signal er
will sich wählen lassen und vorab zeigte
er sich auch zu zugeständnissen an die
cdu bereit man könne gemeinsam über den
neuen haushalt fürs nächste jahr
sprechen
gleichzeitig trifft sich die cdu heute
aber auch zum ersten mal seit dieser
wahl
das war am nachmittag mike mohring kam
heraus der vorsitzende und sagte man
wolle einen vertraulichen gesprächsfaden
und man müsse sich zeit nehmen die frage
ist wie finden sie hier
diesen vertraulichen gesprächsfaden
wieder zurück und wir erinnern uns mike
mohring wollte schon nach der
landtagswahl das gespräch mit bodo
ramelow suchen da wurde er aus berlin
zurück gepfiffen
und es gibt eben immer noch diesen
bundesbeschluss der dazwischen steht
keinen linken ministerpräsidenten zu
wählen
gleichzeitig hier aber eben jene
thüringer verhältnisse die wir haben
also wir warten alle darauf dass bald
hier jemand herauskommt und wir dann
endlich mehr wissen wie es weitergeht
schwierige situation melanie vielen dank
sollte sich in dieser sendung noch etwas
entscheidendes ändern
dann melden wir es natürlich sofort
in dresden läuft gerade die
zweihundertste demonstration der fremden
und islamfeindlichen päda bewegung und
zeitgleich eine gegenkundgebung die
läuft unter dem motto demokratie braucht
rückgrat und richtet sich vor allem
gegen einen auftritt von yonhap
der chef der afg in thüringen soll auf
der pga kundgebung eine rede halten
unser nächstes thema wie kann der
bürgerkrieg in libyen endlich beendet
werden das war thema auf gleich mehreren
internationalen konferenzen unter
anderem einer wichtigen in berlin
das waffenembargo ist in kraft aber bei
weitem nicht alle halten sich daran und
die kämpfe toben weiter
jetzt haben sich die eu-außenminister
nochmal zusammengesetzt und eine neue
marine mission beschlossen mit ihr will
die eu aus der luft und mit schiffen
überwachen dass keine waffen mehr über
das östliche mittelmeer nach libyen
geliefert werden stefan leifert die
bilder werden sich gleichen der auftrag
aber ist ein anderer
mit mission sofia ging die eu gegen
schlepper vor
das wird beendet nun soll eine neue
mittelmeer mission den waffenschmuggel
nach libyen unterbinden überwachung aus
dem wasser genauso wie aus der luft das
ist eine große unterstützung für den
berliner prozess bei dem es im
wesentlichen darum geht die
bürgerkriegsparteien von ihren
unterstützern zu trennen und dafür zu
sorgen dass es keine weiteren
waffenlieferungen mehr geben wird
österreich wehrte sich lange gegen neue
marineboote auf dem mittelmeer
so groß die sorge damit neue schlepper
boote anzuziehen
es geht darum dass wenig deine mission
wollen die weder von schleppern für
geschäftsmodell missbraucht wird
das war in der vergangenheit der fall
weshalb sie auch suspendiert wurde die
beziehung ist sophia was ihr jetzt
wollen ist eine mission die sich ihre
militärischen aufgabe wirklich widmen
kann nämlich darauf zu schauen dass
nicht weitere waffen
damit kommen die neue eu mission soll
sich deswegen allein auf das östliche
mittelmeer beschränken
dort verlaufen die routen der waffen
zulieferer nicht der menschen schlepper
ich glaube dass dieser ganze berliner
prozess dass der nichts taucht werden
wir nicht die überwachung machen was
waffenembargo angeht und auch auf dem
meer libyens kriegsparteien haben laut
un schon 150 mal gegen die waffenruhe
verstoßen
die neue eu mission soll verhindern
helfen dass sie immer neuen nachschub
bekommen aber noch mal kurz reden stefan
das klingt jetzt ein wenig so als
mogelte sich die eu bei dieser mission
weiter um eine entscheidende frage herum
nämlich wie umgehen mit den migranten in
seenot im mittelmeer
ja diese frage bleibt daran hat sich
heute nichts geändert dieser streit geht
unvermindert weiter
und dieser streit hätte heute fast das
ganze auch noch zum scheitern gebracht
das ist jetzt eine einigung auf diese
neue mission gibt hat mit zwei
zugeständnissen in richtung österreich
und ungarn zu tun
das erste zugeständnis ist dass sich die
neue mission ganz streng auf das
östliche mittelmeer zwischen türkei und
libyen beschränkt dort wo im moment
jedenfalls keine schlepper routen
verlaufen und das zweite zugeständnis
ist dass sich die boote sofort wieder
zurückziehen würden in dem fall das
schlepper boote dort auftauchen und die
eu-mission gezwungen wäre flüchtlinge zu
retten das heißt die mission trägt also
ihr eigenes scheitern von anfang an
schon in sich daraus kann man zwei
schlüsse ziehen zum einen sie steht auf
sehr dünnem eis diese mission und zum
zweiten die eu es auch weiterhin nicht
bereit im großen stil flüchtlinge vor
dem ertrinken im mittelmeer zu retten
wichtige erläuterungen aus brüssel
stefan leifert herzlichen dank in
kambodscha wird mittlerweile nach
passagieren eines kreuzfahrtschiffes
gesucht die dort an land gegangen sind
denn bei einer reisenden wurde das
corona virus festgestellt nachdem sie
bereits von bord war das schiff die
westerdam durfte nach tagelanger
irrfahrt letzten donnerstag in einem
kambodschanischen hafen einlaufen
danach ist die mehrzahl der passagiere
in verschiedene länder weitergeflogen
980 passagiere und besatzungsmitglieder
sind noch an bord sie dürfen das schiff
jetzt erst verlassen wenn alle tests auf
das virus negativ ausgefallen sind
nach derzeitigem stand gibt es keine
weiteren ansteckungen
die bundesregierung erwägt die deutschen
passagiere zurückzuholen und das virus
lässt jetzt auch den zeitplan für den
chinesischen volkskongress wackeln
eigentlich sollten sich anfang märz wie
jedes jahr tausende delegierte aus dem
ganzen land in peking versammeln
dahinter steht jetzt ein dickes
fragezeichen und auch in der wirtschaft
geht corona nicht spurlos vorbei
gerade bei den autobauern china ist ja
nicht nur wichtiger exportmarkt dort
sitzen auch große zulieferer mehr von
anselm stern
hier sorgt der virus schon für
stillstand zentralserbien ein werk von
fiat chrysler muss die produktion erst
mal einstellen
es fehlen wichtige teile aus china
corona greift die lieferketten an auch
deutschland könnte das in zukunft
treffen wenn die chinesische virus krise
nicht bald enden sollte nach china sind
natürlich offene volkswirtschaften wie
die deutsche sehr stark vom corona virus
betroffen denn die hälfte unserer
wirtschaftsleistung in deutschland sind
exporte gerade die automobilbranche
erzielt ungefähr ein drittel ihrer
gewinne in china
die großen bmw daimler und vw brauchen
china unbedingt etwa 40 prozent seiner
fahrzeuge verkauft allein der volkswagen
konzern in der volksrepublik im januar
gingen die vw verkäufe in china um mehr
als elf prozent zurück die korea krise
kommt tatsächlich zur unzeit wir haben
eine große transformation in der branche
richtung elektromobilität die sehr viel
geld kostet da würde es sehr negative
auswirkungen haben wenn jetzt die
absatzzahlen und damit umsatz und gewinn
zusammenschmelzen
noch gebe es bei der produktion keine
großen probleme lassen etwa bmw audi und
daimler heute mitteilen
doch das corona virus ist weiter
unterwegs im april sollte wie jedes jahr
die große automesse in china staaten
wichtig vor allem auch für die deutschen
unternehmen
jetzt wurde sie auf unbestimmte zeit
verschoben aus angst vor dem virus
und jetzt geht es ums geld das
elterngeld da soll sich ab dem nächsten
jahr etwas ändern
familienministerin franziska geplant
dass eltern von frühgeborenen länger
elterngeld bekommen
15 statt wie bisher 14 monate wenn das
kind mindestens sechs wochen zu früh zur
welt gekommen ist und so der plan mütter
und väter die schon wieder in teilzeit
zurück im job sind dürfen künftig mehr
arbeiten ohne ihren anspruch auf
elterngeld zu verlieren
32 statt bisher 30 stunden pro woche und
paare mit mehr als 300.000 euro
jahresgehalt sollen in zukunft kein
elterngeld mehr bekommen
bisher liegt die grenze dafür bei
500.000 euro lebenslang wegen mordes das
ist das urteil gegen einen 22-jährigen
autofahrer im april letzten jahres hatte
er sich ab hat er an einem illegalen
autorennen teilgenommen
eine unbeteiligte frau starb mit ihren
rund 600 ps starken autos waren zwei
männer durch ein wohngebiet in moers in
nordrhein-westfalen gerast dominik
möller russ l berichtet kushtrim haar
wollte zeigen dass er der
allerschnellste ist mit mehr als 160
kilometern pro stunde raste er in einem
amg mercedes auf der gegenfahrbahn durch
ein wohngebiet als eine familie mutter
in ihrem blauen kleinwagen in die straße
bog krachte er in sie hinein
die frau starb kurze zeit später
kushtrim haar wusste was er tat so das
landgericht kleve heute deshalb das
urteil lebenslänglich wegen mordes
die kammer hat festgestellt dass der
angeklagte den tod der frau
zumindest für möglich gehalten und auch
billigend in kauf genommen hat denn er
hat sich an das steuer eines über 600 ps
starken boliden gesetzt obwohl er nie
eine fahrerlaubnis hatte bei dem rennen
hat er sein fahrzeug auf über 160
stundenkilometer beschleunigt das obwohl
es draußen dunkel war zu knapp vier
jahren haft verurteilt das gericht den
mitangeklagten mit dem sich kushtrim h
das tödliche rennen lieferte
lebenslänglich für den haupttäter die
angehörigen der getöteten frau begrüßen
die verurteilung wegen mordes
ich habe im rahmen meines schluss
vortrags den wunsch der familie zum
ausdruck gebracht dass ein deutliches
signal in richtung dieser raser szene
erfolgen muss und dieses signal hat das
heute beurteilt sicherlich erbracht das
auto als mordwaffe kushtrim haar kann
das urteil des landgerichts noch
anfechten
albanien ist eines der wirtschaftlich
schwächsten länder europas und bietet
heute offiziell um geld um hilfe nach
dem verheerenden erdbeben ende november
51 menschen kamen ums leben die meisten
into marne und ds 17.000 menschen
verloren ihr zuhause
der sachschaden eine milliarde euro und
dabei legt die gesamte
wirtschaftsleistung von albanien nur bei
14 milliarden euro aus einem
überforderten land berichtet britta
hilpert blumen und bonbons für die toten
kinder
seit dem erdbeben vor knapp drei monaten
kommt diesmal mehr regelmäßig an die
mehr als 20 frischen gräber seine stores
erleichtert mich es ist als ob ich mit
meinen nachbarn rede 6,4 die stärke des
bebens am 26 november frühmorgens in
albanien begruben eingestürzte häuser
ganze familien unter sich menschliches
leid und zerstörte heime das arme land
ist überfordert 200 millionen euro hat
albanien bereitgestellt das reiche nicht
man der premier wir brauchen ungefähr
eine milliarde euro
das ist auch für reiche geberländer kein
kleingeld aber zu schaffen
und das geld kommt heute zusammen rund
1,15 milliarden euro für albanien viel
geld für eine mammut-aufgabe viele hier
in albanien fragen sich wie kann das
wieder aufgebaut werden und vor allem
wie schnell und wie sicher denn zu
schlecht und unkontrolliert wurde in
albanien gebaut sagt bauingenieur nur an
mir deswegen sei so viel eingestellt
das ist wirklich ist die korruption
so kannst du ohne genehmigung bauen
vielleicht ohne ingenieur und kannst
einfach vier ebenen aufstocken
manche privatleute und angie ausbauen
bereits wieder auf mit stärkeren trägern
doch damit dass in ganz albanien
beginnen kann braucht es geld und
kontrolle der ausgaben für bessere und
sicherere häuser teile von wales mittel
und nordengland stehen unter wasser am
wochenende viel mit dem sturm denn ist
so viel regen wie sonst in mehreren
wochen mehr als 1000 menschen mussten
ihre häuser verlassen oft per boot da
die flüsse schnell über die ufer traten
ein mann musste per hubschrauber aus
einem wohnmobil gerettet werden
für viele orte gilt die höchste
alarmstufe weiter denn übermorgen soll
es schon wieder regnen
und damit sind wir in dieser sendung
beim sportlichen mit norbert fußball
champions league achtelfinale morgen
abend dortmund gegen paris st germain
der bvb definitiv ohne seinen verletzten
offensivspieler julian brandt paris
dagegen mit dem wieder genesenen selbst
teilnehmer die laune von bvb-trainer
lucia fahrertyp das aber nicht klar die
dortmunder defensive steht auf dem
prüfstand nach etlichen pannen in dieser
saison und der respekt vor den parisern
ist groß sie waren in eine gruppe von
real madrid sie waren am ende bis 16
punkte und real madrid mit elf punkte
das sagt das sagt auch viel
allerdings untermauern 14 tore in den
letzten drei heimspielen durchaus auch
dortmunder qualitäten auf der
pressekonferenz plauder der schweizer
fahrer heute unter anderem in seiner
muttersprache französisch
hollerith akzentfreien natürlich anders
als später sein pariser kollege thomas
tuchel einst selbst code der borussia
[Musik]
rassismus ekr in portugal der betroffene
mutter maria vom fc porto setzt ein
zeichen der nationalspieler aus mali
verlässt kurz nach seinem siegtor bei
vitoria guimaraes wütend das spielfeld
weil den fans beleidigt und affen
geräusche gemacht hatten
ja und in deutschland ist gegen den
tatverdächtigen der beim drittligaspiel
münster gegen würzburg den gästespielern
ihr all kwadwo ebenfalls rassistisch
beleidigt hatte
ein dreijähriges bundesweites
stadionverbot verhängt worden
alba berlin hat seinen titel trauma
beendet und nach 2016 wieder den
deutschen basketball pokal gewonnen
durch einen 89 zu 67 erfolg gegen
oldenburg in den vergangenen jahren
hatten die albatrosse fünf finalspiele
verloren nun ist zumindest schon mal der
deutsche pokal zurück in berlin
die gäste aus oldenburg in blau-gelb
führten noch knapp zur pause spielten
gut mit dann aber ließen die
hauptstädter den gästen keine chance
mehr 20 punkte gelangen dem isländer
martin herrmann von dem erfolgreichsten
werfer des spiels
vergangene saison haben wir drei final
verloren hätte ich gewusst wie toll
gewinnen ist wenn ich das doch damals
schon gemacht
alba berlin ist zum zehnten mal
deutscher pokalsieger
gewinnen ist was tolles das stimmt mir
langnauer gewitter weiterhin mild dass
es so kurz zusammengefasst das wetter
passt denn terry hat gleich weitere
details ich empfehle ihnen die kollegin
marietta slomka im heute journal um
21.45 bis morgen wenn sie mögen aber
erstmal von uns allen hier in der heute
19 uhr einen angenehmen abend tschüss
[Musik]
ein schirm kunde und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter das ungewöhnliche tiefer
victoria das verabschiedet sich
allmählich hatte auf dem nordatlantik
fast ein rekordwert erreicht immer ein
bisschen 920 hektopascal ist der druck
gesunken
ja aber diese westliche strömung bleibt
uns erhalten und zu erreichen uns
weitere tiefs und sturmtiefs morgen erst
einmal von westen wieder neuer regen
regen gibt es aber auch in der kommenden
nacht und dazu auch gewitter teilweise
schnee bis auf 500 meter herab der wind
ist stramm aus südwest bei temperaturen
von null grad am alpenrand und 6 grad an
der neiße morgen im tagesverlauf neue
schauer vor allem in der nordhälfte
ansonsten nach osten trockener und vor
allem im süden häufiger sonnenschein der
wind ist weiterhin kräftig aus südwest
bis west bei temperaturen von fünf grad
im vogtland und 10 grad ganz im westen
zum beispiel am niederrhein
die nächsten tage am mittwoch wird es
ziemlich ungemütlich mit regen schnee
und gewittern teils mit graupel
gewittern 1 bis 9 grad
ja am donnerstag dann etwas ruhiger und
vor allem freitag relativ viel
sonnenschein bei wenig geänderten
temperaturen ein schöner abend